hi i'm angelica betfellini and i play
blair wesley in teenage bounty hunters
and i'm maddie phillips and we're here
with buzzfeed to play a game of who's
who
you definitely i think that you're
better at
being like deadpan and like keeping
things in i'm more i'm better at being
incognito
yeah i'm not you just give it away
yeah i laugh very easily is it because
of that it's because i laugh so easily
i'm unprofessional i feel like it's i
have so many memories of you
going right hour an hour can i take
it's the same though it's the same thing
i think you were just generally more
prepared to be honest
like to read i like to read and don't
like
to read what's holding my my camera up
right now is books yeah we get it you're
a big fat nerd olympics
both of us yeah it's both of us we're
both really friendly
we're extremely friendly people we're
like so likely to get kidnapped
we're like that friendly
the bed the bed though we had to do a
scene in sterling's bedroom
where blair enthusiastically leaps onto
the bed
and angela was like don't worry i got
this i'm a dancer
so she run i'm a dancer who's been on
broadway no
up less and then like somehow hits her
knee and what they really wanted me to
do was like catapult flying squirrel
starfish arms and legs out and as i did
that they put foam
on your bed frame but not on the corner
so
as i did it i whacked my knee so hard
right into the corner and then i and
then i cried
oh where where's where do i point if i
point at
maddie
yes that's me our costumers made these
things these like patches that you can
iron on to clothes
that said uh zero days which basically
meant there's been zero days since like
i've spilt something
i've fallen things of that nature
and you i'm not a good napper i'll curl
up but i won't really
become unconscious i don't think oh i
would really go to sleep
you know people ask us this but like
we're not being pranksters
we're working you know we're very
professional oh miss women
both of us both of us we're both meme
queens one of our favorite
improvs which is big boy energy there
was actually a meme
that i found that said big boy energy
you give such good advice what can we
say
i think we're both good at doing
impressions
we're both so different i don't know if
there's an answer to this
i'm similar to sterling in that she
really really wears her heart on her
sleeve i find it really hard to like
keep my emotions in
some people have said that i like wear
rose-colored glasses
i think i'm like a very optimistic
person and so is sterling
i don't relate to her in that i have i'm
not
a religious i'm more spiritual
talk about the universe a lot i was not
such a goody two-shoes in school
i would say i think it's hard to like
separate yourself from a character
i think with blair you know she can sort
of be
very dramatic which i have definitely
can relate to
in my life and she can be kind of like a
confetti that explodes and
does everything all at once all at the
same time and her brain works really
fast and
um i definitely relate to that but i
also think that
um i can have quiet tender moments
that perhaps blair still has a little
ways to go and maybe that comes with age
it's therapeutic for me to play a 16
year old who sort of
knows exactly what she wants because
when i was her age i did not know
i was a late bloomer
you're more likely to bring around a
real camera and i'm more likely to just
like
document everything i miss you i wish we
were in the same room
i know don't remind me
you